come a knock on my door with the wedding
of a Molina leave it with mine any tune
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube now you
guys have been asking me to cover this
topic and we are gonna have a discussion
on it today I'm a little bit confused
when it comes to this so it's gonna be
an open discussion or relatively hoping
cuz I'm according this video and then
putting the opinion so why I want to
hear you guys discuss it's in a very
positive and very informative way
without getting [ __ ] angry about what
you think when it comes to the topic of
Azis and sorry not just to give you guys
a quick recap of who aziz ansari is he
is a highly acclaimed a writer actor
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] things I'm not
successful person but the controversy
around him stems from a lady who remains
anonymous who wanted to talk about Aziz
Ansari and the whole me to movement
about how he sexually harassed or
assaulted her just to give you guys a
short clip notes of what happens and
remember read the articles yourself and
do your own research she met Aziz Ansari
was very interested in him was thrilled
by the fact that he was Aziz Ansari went
to go see him he kind of like brushed
her off like yes but later on they
started talking again during the night
shared some drinks might have had some
food went over to his place and they
basically got it on he basically
performed oral sex on her with her
consent she then performed oral sex on
him with her consent as well but
throughout the night I guess she was
giving a lot of like nonverbal cues that
she felt uncomfortable but it didn't
really change how things went down and
still they had sex mind you throughout
this whole thing she doesn't MIT that
she gave him consent he was not holding
her there he did not threaten her he
didn't force anything upon her or
anything like that but afterwards she
left and she converts with them through
text that she felt very uncomfortable
and she felt that he took advantage of
her too that he did replied that he was
confused and he didn't know that's how
she felt and he apologized this is what
I took away from what she wrote when it
comes to public opinion it doesn't seem
that people are split when it comes to
the situation right from what I've read
it seems that 80% are kind of on like
Aziz Ansari side saying that they don't
really understand what she's talking
about
and quote-unquote she's tripping and
tripping like I'm a [ __ ] seventy year
old man she
tripping but the other 20% empathizes
with her and they say that you know what
I kind of been in that situation to
where these guys don't understand
nonverbal cues and they kind of take
advantage of the fact that you can't say
no now I don't really have a bias when
it comes to this but there are a few
things that I do want to discuss and I
could be wrong I don't know somebody
could probably change my mind and that's
why you leave this open for discussion
in the comments now for me the things
that are clear about every single
article when it comes to this topic is
how things went down she was invited
over she said yes he performed oral sex
on her she didn't say no she didn't
object to it she didn't push his head
away and she accepted it things got a
little weird she went into the bathroom
to kind of shake it off she didn't feel
right about it she told him that big
things cool down
he made a move again I think for me and
this is not me saying this as a guy I
don't want to take away something called
personal responsibility now this doesn't
mean that as Lisa's always approach to
how he kind of like expected certain
things Roberta was a little bit odd and
just weird and maybe a little gross too
and that before you go ahead and jump
down my [ __ ] throat listen to what
I'm saying I always think about these
type of situations about personal
responsibility because I hold myself to
that same standard it was always the
option of no I don't want to I don't
feel comfortable and I can leave this
situation at any given time that I want
some people object to this but you can't
just glaze over it like it's nothing the
option of no and the option of I am a
woman I am in control of my own body and
my own domain and if I said to him no I
don't want this I could leave that
option was on the [ __ ] table and the
reason why I bring a personal
responsibility just to wrap back to it
is basically because of this I dislike
when people talk about women empowerment
and being a feminist and they talk about
personal responsibility but they want to
pick and choose when it's right but when
it comes to women empowerment and being
in control of what's going on it's like
that no means no yes means yes say
clearly what you want I am in control of
my own domain
I completely a hundred percent agree but
when it comes to this case there's this
rhetoric of I believe in women and their
choices and their empowerment and
personal responsibility but I
really have control of this situation
because Aziz Ansari was there and I
didn't know what to do and that really
doesn't fly with me how can you say that
you want personal responsibility that
you want to take control of your own
destiny but when something doesn't go
favorably for you and you regret your
actions later that was as you said it
was consensual then you say I don't have
control of my own destiny and I find
that just infuriating the whole meet to
movement is very important and I'm in
full support of it because we all
realize that in Hollywood whether you
guys are a part of it or not there is
this huge power struggle and there's a
lot of powerful people out there that
will use that power to take advantage of
people specifically women it's not
hearsay anymore it's fact people are
coming out with this and it should be
[ __ ] heard but the issue that I have
are certain people that want to be a
part of this me tube movement but if
they don't really belong in it because
it's like hey if you used your sexuality
to get what you wanted and you kind of
did your way all the way to the top you
gain the whole world but then you go you
know what this person took advantage of
me you're not a part of the [ __ ] me
tube movement you use your sexuality to
get what you wanted and then you
benefited from it and now you want to be
a part of these women who are taking
advantage of that were sexually
assaulted you you cannot put yourself in
that [ __ ] category those women are
traumatized they were put in
compromising situations when it came to
their [ __ ] career and then you want
to talk about you want to be a part of
me too when you sucked your dick all the
way to the [ __ ] top no that doesn't
work and you're making a mockery of that
social move and that's very [ __ ]
important right now just to clarify I'm
not saying that she is a part of this
movement but what I am saying is that we
should be conscious about the stories
that we are telling is Aziz Ansari a
[ __ ] rapist in my personal opinion
absolutely [ __ ] nut is it a bad date
yes it was should he have picked up on
these nonverbal cues probably but to his
credit they did have a conversation
after about what happened he apologized
and he said he didn't know that's how he
felt I mean come on we have to give
credit to that and just to add to this
topic I think this is also a huge
reflection about how important like
sexual education is beyond just learning
like body parts but just to understand
appropriate like sexual cues and how
people should feel about their sexuality
sexual education should also be about
this topic right here about how to
conduct yourself around somebody else
and to understand what somebody is
comfortable with having sex or not did
they give you guys a personal story like
sex wasn't really talked about in my
house and the only version of like
sexual talk that I had was probably from
a bunch of dudes that were just making a
bunch of [ __ ] dick jokes and talking
about [ __ ] women and in case you
haven't picked up that's not really a
good form of [ __ ] sexual education so
when it came to my very first girlfriend
and when we had sex
I was absolutely terrible at it I had no
idea what the [ __ ] I was doing I had no
idea what that speed bag was about the
vagina and on top of me not knowing what
the [ __ ] I was doing she didn't know
what the [ __ ] she was doing as well it
was a terrible experience for both of us
with my very first girlfriend I'll
openly admit I didn't understand like
nonverbal cues and it was because she
wasn't comfortable with her sexuality I
wasn't comfortable with my sexuality so
I didn't know how to make her feel
comfortable so it was just two kids who
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
it was by far probably the worst
situation I could have ever been in we
would be in weird situations that I
reflect on now where she would be in the
[ __ ] mood I wouldn't know I would be
in the mood
she wouldn't [ __ ] know and it was
just so confusing because both of us
didn't and didn't know how to talk about
it we didn't converse about it properly
not until the next girl that I got
sexually active with we actually had
conversations about what the [ __ ] was
going on and by the way just to put it
out there this [ __ ] was [ __ ] brutal
as hell you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing why don't you try this what
the [ __ ] were you [ __ ] were you
[ __ ] a sandbag [ __ ] I have feelings
but I learned a lot from her because she
taught me a lot about number one the
woman's body parts number two how to
openly communicate with somebody tell
them what you like and dislike it when
the S means yes and window means no and
it clearly stated but my first
girlfriend it was so [ __ ] difficult I
had to figure it out myself and every
time I got it wrong I was like I don't
know what the [ __ ] you want but I was
too shy to actually tell him like hey
can you tell me yes and no clearly so I
just I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on but she taught me a lot she taught me
how to communicate properly when it came
to these type of things and if it wasn't
for her I probably you know would be a
disease it sorry and the crappy thing is
not every woman's gonna be like that
harsh [ __ ] not every girl's gonna be
open up to say hey we need to talk about
this openly and let's discuss like how
we feel what we like what we dislike how
we want to communicate when yes means
yes and when no means no and when I'm
flirting and what I'm not flirting not
all women are like that and so I do
believe it is up to some
body out there to educate us like I
think that this should be put into
sexual education and by the way just to
recap in case anybody is so [ __ ]
stupid and dumb out there yes yes always
nice yes and no always means no when it
comes to people that you absolutely
don't know but you know sometimes when
you with your girlfriend she goes no and
the guys look like stop to stop it
you know there'll be like the flirting
yes and the flirting no it's not like
I'm saying she said no I don't want it
I'm like [ __ ] you flirt a bad it was
more like here take it but I want people
to take this moment to have a
conversation on my channel about it and
to really ask how they feel about it
without getting angry and cursing people
out let's let's have a conversation
listeners converse about this because
I'm confused as [ __ ] I actually don't
know how to feel because I do believe
that both sides have something very
important to say and the good and the
positive that came out of this was that
we are talking about this when it comes
to like consensual sex and how you
should feel about personal
responsibility when you do these type of
things so let's talk about this and I'll
see y'all next time
you